hey what is up guys my name is the
Cherno welcome to episode 19 is it is
this episode 19 are we up to that I
don't even remember it's been that long
I think this is episode 19 of game
programming and I've honorable I
finished school like unbelievable like
the joy that is in me right now is
indescribable like it's amazing it's the
best feeling I've probably ever had in
my life knowing that like I was I was
eating dinner sorry I was eating lunch
just just like earlier today and and I
was thinking okay let's say I'm gonna
have to go upstairs back to my room what
do I have to do and then the thought
occurred to me absolutely nothing like
there is legitimately nothing except for
your this YouTube stuff that I actually
need to do like the feeling is is is
heavenly that's the only way I can
actually describe it but um we're back
we're back guys this will continue to be
a daily series from now on as it was
before exams so yeah sit back and joy
and hopefully this this game will be
finished before you know it
alright so right now what we've got in
the last episode just to refresh your
memories and mine is um is this this
window thing right with a bunch of tiles
on the screen now the next step and
obviously like this isn't necessarily
the next step right because we could do
anything next that's the thing like the
order of episodes doesn't matter that
much the thing that I do next you could
do later on and again the thing that I
do a few episodes later you do now okay
but so the order that I do this game in
is just a preference that I think would
be better just for just for me really
just just for whatever feature I think
of adding next so what I want to do now
is actually basically make sprites right
because I want these these squares to be
filled up with actual sprites I want us
to be able to design a picture basically
in a in a program and then actually
replace these colors with that actual
that picture so that's creating textures
and sprites now what our sprites if you
don't know what sprites are sprites are
2d
images now they're not 3d images if it's
a 3d image is actually called an it's
quite it's actually called a model this
is a 2d game thus you know what actually
using 3d models were using 2d images
they're called sprites so just remember
that whenever the word sprite is used
it means 2d two-dimensional okay
again if it's 3d if it's 3d is a model
so what we actually need to do now is
have a way to actually import a sprite
sheet and that's what we're gonna talk
about today making a sprite sheet now
the first thing I'm just gonna do is
actually remember this size of our
sprite so it looks like the map size of
64 it looks like we're multiplying it by
16 or actually dividing by 16 so I guess
ask for eye sizes 16 all right I think
so yeah I'll wait 16
we're at 16
I think I think the sprite size is 16
okay I want to I want to make it 16
anyway so we'll just assume it is 16 so
what we actually need to do now is
create a spreadsheet now what is a
spreadsheet because I picked because out
because our sprites are actually going
to be 16 by 16 pixels that's relatively
small so we don't actually once we have
each individual sprite in a different
file we just want to have a bunch of
sprites in one image and then we can
sort of sort through which sprite we
actually want to extract from that image
and use that'll actually that'll
actually reduce memory usage because
we're going to have to load in about I
don't know 200 files wolves have to use
what wolves have to load in one file and
that'll actually have the 200 sprites in
it so great example is paint.net right
we're gonna make our sprite sheet in
paint.net that's just what I'm using now
first of all I'm gonna go to the image
here and select canvas size and I'm
gonna make it 256 by 256 that is the
size of that canvas now I'll probably
increase that in the future I'm not sure
but for now it's gonna be this size it
okay and now I'm actually gonna use a
plug-in under effects called grid now
you can download this plug-in from the
Internet
all you do honestly is you just go to
google and you type in grid plug-in
paint.net okay I'll actually link the
plug-in in the description because
inevitably some of you guys will
probably won't be able to find it mm-hmm
and again I'm just doing this from
memory so I don't think I know how to
get to it but we'll find it and I'll
post it in the description so you guys
can click on that and download this
plugin it's very useful so as you can
see this generates a grid and we can
make the size 16 right because that's
the size of our sprites 16 and we'll
just hit OK actually one more thing
before we hit okay now that'll be fun
all right
Isabella so what we've got here is this
grid right and every one of these
sprites every one of these sorry every
one of these cells is actually going to
be a sprite so we'll start in the top
left corner really we're not gonna make
any surprise today we're just gonna load
this sprite sheet into our game so we've
made this sprite sheet now all we have
to do is actually save so we'll go to
save as and I'll actually pop over to my
eclipse workspace I think will be the
game programming workspace and over here
in rain which is the name of this
project right we've got folders or two
folders here I'm actually gonna make a
new folder called re s now res it stands
for resources and this is going to
contain all the resources that we use so
stuff like sound images video files
potentially pop another any resources
that are out basically external so not
card they'll all be contained in this
folder and in here I'm just going to
name it spreadsheet actually almost a
I'm problematic folder in res called
textures and then I'll just call sprite
shape and that's all that's it as a PNG
it's safe okay so now that that's saved
now we actually need to load this into
the game and we'll do that by actually
putting a new class so on the under the
graphics package when I right click and
create a new class and we'll just call
it sprite shape and this class is
actually going to be in charge of
managing any sprite sheets that we might
have and actually caching them you know
to memory to a to a variable so what
we'll do here first of all is actually
specify the path for that for a
particular sprite sheet we might
actually have multiple sprites because
we might have a separate sprite sheets
for stuff like outdoor graphics indoor
graphics you know what I mean like we
might have multiple sprite kids because
we don't want to cram all like I don't
know say we have 200 surprised we don't
really want cram 200 eyes into one
sprite rate that might get a bit
confusing we want to sort of be able to
break it down as much as possible but in
moderation as well so we don't have 200
sprite shades so we'll create a a string
here and we'll make it um private
private string path and it's actually
just going to contain the path to our
spreadsheet so the the system path will
also make a private final int size and
capitalize it because that's a
convention if you're making something
final you usually capitalize it again
you don't have to but that's just a
convention one side of equal to anything
yet actually
equal to know about settle tempting and
but also create a private
sorry-sorry where we'll create a public
int and we'll call it pixels all right
so we've heard it three variables now
now what we want to do is actually
create a constructor for the class
so public spreadsheet and I'll take two
parameters first one is the path to our
spreadsheet to that particular
spreadsheet and the second one is the
size of the spreadsheet and then under
here all we need to do is say this the
path equals path and this dot size
equals size okay again we've made the
size variable final because the size of
the spreadsheet will never change so the
size of the spreadsheet does not mean
the size of the sprites
it means the size of the sprite sheet
now it is square as you know there's the
the width is equal to the length or the
width is equal to the height and it's
256 by 256 so literally it will be 256
in this case we might have a small
spreadsheet in the future and that's
pretty much it and then in pixels we
actually need to set the pixels array
equal to new int size times size and
we'll actually probably just use of this
one and we probably also didn't really
need this here so again what this code
is gonna do is it's gonna set this thing
equal to whatever we input here which
you'll see it demonstrated it in a
minute and again it's going to set this
size equal to this size that's how it's
gonna work
and then it's gonna create that pixel
equal to the size of our spreadsheet so
in other words we're gonna have we're
gonna have every pixels of every pixel
of this spreadsheet mapped out so that
we can access them now the most
important part is actually loading that
spreadsheet
oops closes for now
the other important thing again yeah is
loading that sprite [ __ ] so we've made a
way to sort of create it in Java but now
we actually need to load that physical
image file so I'll probably just make a
private method here called probably call
it Lord load image or blog just load and
what I want to do here is again just
type Buffett image oops
Buffett image image fools image IO dot
read and we'll just go sprite sheet dot
plus dot resource and again we'll use
path so what this is gonna do is
basically create a new Buffett image
object which is basically an image and
it's going to set that image equal to
the image of this path that's all this
code is going to do it and we'll import
this and you'll see this actually throws
an exception
so we'll just surround it with try and
catch alright so what do we now is we're
actually loading that image into a
buffered image class but we don't really
want to deal with images in Java as a
buffered image we want to deal with them
as individual pixels like we have in the
past okay like we like we have with
these with these colors over here right
we want to deal with them as individual
pixels so to do that we need to create
two quick variables that will actually
you know dispose of eventually then on
permanent that's why we're creating them
in here
so the width of the shape so image don't
care with again the width will roughly
be equal to the size but just in case we
want to be able to do it from here and
image get hide so this is getting the
height and width of this image that is
loaded which is found in path whatever
path maybe and now I want to do we
actually want to set those pixels so now
we know the width and height we want to
reset this buffered image into this into
this pixel array and the way we do that
is we just simply call a void method
which is image get RGB and over here we
need our start X which is where we start
anning so 0 start why so zero comma zero
is the coordinate where we actively
start loading the image from because we
want the entire image right width and
height that's already done for us again
this is referring to these variables so
this this in turn this basically covers
the entire image now the RGB array is
where we actually want to store those
RGB pixels so we want we obviously want
to store them in this pixel array so
pixels the offset of where it actually
starts scanning is going to be zero
again is scanning horizontally so we
want it to start at zero and then the
scan size is again I just mentioned it
scans horizontally so the scan size will
actually be the width and obviously
width is actually equal to height
because it's a square but doesn't matter
so that is the code that actually
translates this image that we've loaded
into these pixels okay and that is Liam
legitimately it all we have to do is
after we've created all this we can just
clicking this called the load method
once as we've done as we've done here
and it will actually set these pixels
equal to the sprite shape all right
equal to that spreadsheet file so that's
it take down all this code get ready
because tomorrow we're gonna look look
at a way to actually implement this and
probably make a sprite class and
actually manage individual sprites but
um that's it guys I really hope you
enjoyed this episode please hit the like
button if you did leave a comment let me
know what you thought and I'll see you
guys tomorrow with a brand new episode
so until then later guys
[Music]